If you look at a country like the United States,
the share of the total income going to the
top ten percent of the population used to
be about one third of the total income back
in the early 1980s and now in 2015 It is over
one half.
So it has gone from 30/35 percent to over
50 percent of total income.
Marx in the 19th century says that inequality
would have to rise forever.
Kuznets in the 20th century on the contrary
assumes that there were natural forces that
would make inequality go down in the long
run.
My main conclusion is that there are powerful
forces going in both directions and that ultimately
which one dominates really depends on the
institutions policy that we choose in the
area of education, labor market, taxation,
corporate governance, minimum wages.
And all of these matter and there are several
possible futures.
If your parents are rich like 100 percent
of the generation almost goes to college.
If your parents are poor it's like 20/30 percent
going to college and these are not the same
colleges if you're rich.
And so there's very unequal access to education
prevents inequality from going down.
Now, even if you get education policy right
there are other forces which can lead to rising
inequality in the long run.
In particular there is a tenancy of the rate
of return to capital to exceed the economies
growth rate in the very long run can act as
a powerful force to very high concentration
of wealth and property as opposed to income
inequality, in particular labor income inequality,
which is primarily damning by education and
labor market institution.
So again, it really depends on the institution
and policies like progressive taxation of
income, wealth that we put in place in order
to regulate these dynamics.
Sometimes people want just to blame globalization
and say because of globalization, because
of the competition with emerging countries
inequality has to increase and in any case
there's not much we can do about it; that's
just globalization.
And I think this is wrong.
I believe in globalization but I believe we
also need strong democratic institution and
fiscal and educational policies so as to ensure
that more people actually benefit from globalization
so you don't have the same rise in inequality
everywhere.
For instance, in Europe and Japan where you
also have globalization and competition with
the emerging countries, inequality of income
or wealth did not increase quite as much as
in the United States.
So this shows a different course of action
can make a difference.